but Dallas man I want to do a shout out
to this kid Grady Pruitt again Grady
over the kid from Houston I was talking
about the one he said killed you killed
he came to Dallas and can I tell you
something about Grady Pruitt what I love
them
is he was there 24/7
Wow he picked me up he was there do this
he's there
not only is he great on stage he owes us
fish eyes ever tell you about that
brandy fish I know like Michael Shannon
always pops out of the song yeah pops
out of it like like like off of the
sides of his face like that and we're
ripping on them all weekend we would we
would we would Google photos of frogs
like that yeah but and he would take it
and so this kid Grady Pruett he's out of
Houston he won funniest comic out of
Texas um he's gonna be he's gonna move
to LA and we're gonna help him did you
guys get pulled over we got pulled over
the police and I got him out of it how
how'd you know we got pulled over he
told me why else would I know you got
pulled over over because he has no
bumper or like anything like his engine
is like exposed and we get pulled over
and I go I said to Grady I go he was
that kind of sweating he's like I think
man sir I don't have my registrations on
you know means like honey we're spring
things to myself you know could it must
have been embarrassed for him I'm the
headliner and as soon as the cop and it
was a Mexican cop and thank God when
it's a Mexican cop we're clear yeah do
you know why because every Mexico daddy
they know what MADtv is so great he's
like can I see your license and
registration his town was weird yeah and
I picked my head like Oh what's up bro
like that confident and he looked at me
and he went oh hey yeah go we were just
headlight you know I hadn't lighting
that the impro right there you know and
this guy drove from Houston he's a comic
and he emceed for me and I made him come
drive all the way to Dallas and my
friend Nick is you know featuring we
were at the Walgreens and we're just
driving these driving us
back he's like okay well I still need to
look at his butt I'll be right back and
he went back for a couple of seconds
came back and he goes yeah I mean it's
there's some you know things that aren't
in order but we'll let it slide I can
thank you and then you know we're fine
if it was white we'd be dead all of you
know if it was a white cop we would not
if you talked in your desert Bob at some
tacky dose yeah but you know what's so
funny about also Texas is because I've
been traveling there the last couple
months
it is especially I mean the towns that
I've been in Houston Dallas El Paso even
it's pretty you don't feel like there's
any kind of racism or any kind of
prejudice I mean you see white dudes
with cowboy hats and they're like how
you doing buddy
you're like what's up man yeah I like
your shoes and you're like thanks like
your face and you move on there's no cuz
my you know I I told Steve I go I go to
Texas like I've never been there have
you racist would they kill you you're
like do they think people that haven't
been in Texas they think that there's
like you know guys walking around with
guns and you know I'm in but it's like a
lot of Asians a lot of Asian dudes with
white chicks at the shows Tiger belly
fans of course of all of all shout out
the Tiger colonizing yeah colonizing but
um I love Texas a lot I've always loved
it if you have you've been there right
yeah of course Houston has a lot of
Vietnamese I was really shocked a lot of
Vietnamese crawfish yeah there's a lot
of nurses that are moving to Houston
because they have a lot of like
big signing bonuses so we're like
medical professionals and like are
moving for some reason there's like this
new trend of a lot of fool a lot of
medical professionals moving to Texas
and then you know you go to San
Francisco or Sacramento in that area you
see among the Hmong people yeah in
Sacramento yeah and they were the Hmong
people I don't know much about history
or where they're from but I think
they're from like a mountainous region
in Tibet or something and they were
driven out by the Chinese government or
and then they were spread all over the
world and a lot of them ended up in
Cleveland and some in Sacramento oh I
went to school with like a lot of Hmong
in North Carolina when I dropped out of
college
really and everyone thought I was mom
cuz that's the only Asian they had was
mom well you look mom I know I I was
like damn yeah yeah pretty much yeah
like I could see my like I'm Eagle just
land on your shoulder you're mean and go
get me a deer or whatever like Mulan
yeah the Hun's Eagle hunters that's what
it is oh yeah yeah it's amazing
[Music]